[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es ein superschnelles rezept
wir machen ein pott pasta
wir sind gerade mitten im dreh und ich
habe heute zwei süße rezepte gemacht und
jetzt hatten wir alle natürlich sehr
hunger wir haben 13 uhr 10 und möchte
jetzt was herzhaftes essen
da bietet sich so ein wort rezept also
einen eintopf sozusagen perfekt an und
zwar mache ich hier schon ging's mit ein
bisschen brokkoli und spinat also halten
wir das ganze ein bisschen grün und
braun heute als ich an meine koalition
ist es aber nicht denn es ist ein sehr
leckeres rezept
wir wissen ja und das rezept können wir
natürlich auch abwandeln ihr könnt auch
stadt der saane zb kokosmilch nehmen und
das ganz einfach auch vegan zu bereiten
ich zeige euch jetzt mal die zutaten die
ich verwende und ihr könnt wie gesagt an
geeigneter stelle auch zutaten abwandeln
also das rezept brauche ich 250 gramm
braune champignons ein brokkoli den habe
ich bereits in röschenz erteilt ich habe
ich noch 200 gramm baby spinat eine
zwiebel 1 knoblauchzehe hier sind 500
gramm nudeln ein liter wasser dafür
benutze ich auch gleich meine
gemüsebrühe selbstgemachte und 200 gramm
sahne und natürlich eventuell noch salz
pfeffer und vielleicht ein bisschen
chili das wird jetzt auch alles ganz
einfach zubereitet ich werde jetzt die
champignons einfach in scheiben
schneiden
[Musik]
die zwiebel und knoblauchzehe mit ganz
fein gewürfelt
und den brokkoli teile ich einfach in
kleine röschen 1
und jetzt habe ich alle zutaten
vorbereitet und gehe es jetzt hier in
einen großen topf wer möchte kann
natürlich zuerst die zwiebel und
knoblauchzehen anbraten ich lasse es ist
weg bei uns wird es ein ganz einfaches
gericht das einzige was ich jetzt
erstmal noch rauslassen ist der spinat
da kommt nämlich am ende erst mit dazu
[Musik]
ich lebe jetzt hier meine selbstgemachte
gemüsebrühe da findet er das rezept
bereits auf meinem kanal und da gebe ich
dann einfach nach geschmack dazu und
natürlich wasser aber falls ihr keine
selbstgemachte gemüsebrühe habt könnt
ihr natürlich auch ein liter fertige
gemüsebrühe verwenden
jetzt kommt das immer mit rein die sahne
und wie gesagt gebe ich noch ein
bisschen chili mit rein und pfeffer und
das war jetzt schon mal der schwierigste
part des gbc den deckel drauf und lass
dir zutaten aufkochen und dann zehn
minuten lang köcheln und dann am ende
kommt es dass spinat dazu
das sind zehn minuten vorbei und die
zeit die zähne ich immer erst ab dann
wenn das ganze schon aufgekocht ist das
heißt aufkochen lassen und dann erst
zehn minuten runter wobei er auch bis
auf die nudel sorte ankommt jetzt kommt
hier das spinat mit das so
dann kurz einrühren standard was das
ziel ist noch ganz viel aus aber das
wird gleich ganz wenig und wer möchte
kann jetzt auch noch ein bisschen
parmesan dazu geben und das ganze
gericht für weitere zwei bis drei
minuten lang kochen bis der spinat ein
bisschen verfallen ist und wir können
jetzt schon mal den tisch richten denn
es gibt gleich essen gedacht hallo freut
ihr euch nicht
[Musik]
ich bin bereit ich bin so froh dass das
wetter hält
spongebob ist mein instrument
wahrscheinlich patchkabel gleich mein
kommentar schreibt wahrscheinlich dass
oliver morath studios probieren
ich mach mal dazu zählen wir wollen auch
dass er viel grün viel grün und ich habe
zehn papin kerle gerüstet vegetarisch
denn sahne aber man kann er die sahne
ganz einfach so ich hab jetzt chili so
nach sally gut man kann es auch gerne
ganz vegan zu retten indem man die sahne
weg ist schon ganz schön aus und ich
finde die farben voll schön dass ich
super schnell zubereitet und ihr seht
auch am ende sieht es aus als wenn zu
viel flüssigkeit noch drin aber ich
lasse dann immer ganz kurz stehen zur 23
minuten und dann ziehen die nudeln sich
noch mal voll und parmesan habe ich
jetzt vergessen darüber zu reden wie
parmesan noch trüber beim sanieren grund
lege branche show sally mark sanchez
gerade das tut mir leid das war mein
thema das ihn ruhig stehen nicht erst
denn hier ist wo ich glas wasser gehen
oder meine leser was ja also falls ihr
auch dieses rezept zubereiten wollt dann
schaut auf meinem blog vorbei ist alice
- blog.de ich wünsche euch viel spaß
beim nachmachen die noch im guten
appetit tun und auch in guten appetit
und bis zur nächsten wahl ganz schnell
ganz ohne soße ganz schnell
ja ich habe mit soße aber eben ohne tüte
man ohne twitter ganz genau
und man kann es auch ab wann man kann ja
auch champignons keine angst macht so
mag ich zum beispiel pfifferlinge vorlag
wenn du grad celsius kann man die mit
rein geben oder was ganz anderes also
was ihr da habt
der bruch und ja auch gut
ferner kommt ich privat nämlich jetzt
eine chili hier ein topf untergehen es
dann auch
oder in sydney
[Musik]
ja